all right I hope this recording is
actually working was a bit strange here
all right so a couple of three minutes
game coming up and let's see what
happens here I'm playing international
master here from from Britain from the
UK and have some rate ear opening here
try to open up the position quickly okay
I like to keep my pawn structure intact
iam sorry Knight takes e4 wasn't without
its point see them wondering about if 5
p.m.
yeah maybe this mentoring the bishop
immediately and I am b7 pawn could be a
good idea only to be consciously because
of my development which isn't so great
he might have something on f2 at some
point okay so from a structural point of
view this is nice also two bishops but
move like 94 years bit irritating
yeah so how do I protect this actually
rook f1
hmm yeah I might need to rook d2 also
possible but not sure it makes a huge
difference
yeah okay maybe he can try to play h3
now can he do some sacrifice not sure
well don't think so I think he needs to
retreat now so what now how do I get my
pieces out here
he's got 93 also as an idea which is
also not noise not nice at all okay
maybe I should try to exchange something
here also when protecting the d3 square
so that I maybe just maybe just take it
okay but I don't need to take right away
right time money yeah it's really not
nice I can play this kind of move first
and see what he's doing
yeah I have absolutely no possibilities
here to play active moves okay I need to
get rid of this piece doesn't help now
I'm trying to get on the CFL
yeah position is okay I'm very much down
on time due to the difficulties earlier
but I'm certainly not worse here try to
get rid of one sock one rookie here
maybe I should have taken no no
yeah there's not much going on here it's
not really besides the fact that I'm low
on time try to catch up a bit on the
clock here not caring so much about the
position
hard to believe that you can do all this
with a skin so maybe this is really the
case
check check check check
I can take h6 now yes black orchids on
time yeah well what can you do typical
time scramble not so sure what what what
what this position is I mean am I losing
probably means equal material but his F
pawn is very dangerous this might be
lost yeah now I can just take III but it
was just time time scramble just moving
and blundered this piece and the one no
time at the end was 2 versus 2 seconds
or something yeah mom it's 2 minutes
three minutes yes what can you do
alright next game I lost so many your
time before getting started okay
Queens gambit of the islands okay you
had them many good lines against this
opening I often played this III line
I was wondering what's what's plex
point is here really it starts weakening
himself and so on yeah well this is just
yeah and he plays it all all immediately
okay so now to refute this okay let's
let's win some Tempe first I will the
problem with three minutes three minutes
always tricky timewise your Queenie Sam
might be might be really an idea
hmm so okay I need to get a square for
the king or d1 so yeah he takes them he
takes a three maybe wasn't the best I
mean still I like my position like I saw
I mean this is all in this array here
King on d1 also isn't brilliant but so
what now b5 he back castles long oh cool
yeah so okay let's try to open it up b5
on 95 I just play rook e1 mm-hmm he
might take you might take on d3 then
okay
yeah he might take on d3 alright some
chocolate some uses tempo now Queen a7
checkmate threatened rope human another
another tempo gain really okay okay
let's let's take this tempo also so yeah
okay this looks like I mean should I be
totally winning here everything else
would be hugely unfair really I don't
see a woman Bishop d7 II can take should
before I can play at g7 but should be it
should be okay anyway I can play Bishop
f1 and now he's got no square to retreat
her just this
okay so Bishop f4 was was my my plan so
g3m my money
g3 planning Bishop f4 I think he needs
to play a move like g5 now to actually
prevent this
yeah okay so what now taking and brookey
six or something hmm
we might have a check okay so this is
the other idea getting rid of the this
nights maybe this is the most direct way
to do it
rainy somewhat weird position but okay
1996 it's really a winning threat here
and what should you do don't see you
move really okay
yeah but rookie idea I've got so he
takes with an ID rupee aid it's also
curtains no move Queen eight seven mate
what night see eight let's see eight
okay clap resigned
you know night see a true create also
over alright yeah this was just too
insane I mean the Albans is really
really a bit bit of risky I mean it's
not not entirely incorrect or something
but really risky game started okay so
some international master here from from
Italy okay let's go for Kings Indian set
up and see what is doing okay is going
for for some English opening
okay I'll try to exchange this strong
bishop on g2 with Bishop h3 again let's
let's get rid of this piece it's really
a bit a bit annoying so what does he do
it in c5 I'd be six okay
okay I need to need to keep this
disclosed here maybe I can go for
further very simple let's play it simple
chassis attacking h2
now I just need to dislodge this knight
on f3 and his and he's gone nine h4 he
would need to take with the pawn I take
with the queen who it's not not so
stupid but maybe if maybe I should try
to prepare this a bit more
or simply h 5 h 5 h 4 is also not bad at
all
should I play you for years but whiskey
maybe I cannot yet sacrifice something
anywhere I might well he might have 95
the silly mafia
ah this is stupid I didn't really think
about 95 yeah the problem is it's it's a
whole Rokia it's not not just an
exchange
okay so might need to go back here it's
not what I wanted to do obviously I
really stupid yeah this looks shaky
Queen B 2 and stuff like this check time
morning I do I just so all you is
terribly loud yeah I'm not sure if you
really has got some knockout now move
lock Knight f6 now it's not bad but I'm
not sure that it wins out right okay
just detects the Queen okay I don't want
to exchange Queens yet maybe I can get
Gary for at least e3 is saying now oops
hmm yeah it's not playing that bad at
all please them quite decisive play from
from from white ok guess I need to cover
yeah eight but it's maybe not entirely
clear I'm not sure those Knights are not
doing so much at the moment
95 to reform yeah but this is a pin also
time the time okay so I'm glad to get to
this ok so what's happening here I'm two
pawns at a download time check check
check
rook h3 yet shame check check check
check check
yeah yeah or pre-move no okay let's get
let's do it row here draw maybe I could
have tried on on time even at the end he
was so slow yeah yeah I should have won
this but of course I wasn't huge trouble
before
so maybe okay result okay next game
no I'm not getting again hmm
we had three minute games usually you
get really quickly and now nothing's
happening at all I pressed this button
right yeah okay so here's the next game
um okay let's go if or you play oops
92 loop in bed okay so we transpose into
a Sicilian here let's see what line is
playing okay the Jomon of Alden line
just developing normally him age five
yeah he wants to go naughty for you
not sure this position h5 is really a
really irritates me I think with the
bishop on d3 this is a known line not
not sure about this really won't be five
what about a five now what what do you
play that maybe a second spawn no g4
yeah I need to go matcha formerly
everything else just looks I mean back
to g8 cannot be the idea 95 I just take
and black is in terrible shape with this
pawn structure he needs to go natural
for now for better or worse I mean okay
this is cool I didn't didn't see that
really mine okay didn't play he didn't
plan it also but okay I need to grab the
knight cannot never move in the night
and then he plays 95 himself
so um okay recapture yeah so so quite a
sharp position here so should I take H 5
it's not so much the pawn I'd like to
put pressure on f7 okay I'll practice
yeah we should be seven I guess I was
actually thinking about stuff like f-5e
596 stuff like this I said yeah but ok
h2s is an issue oh this is cool I mean
he's got nothing developed and just
moves around with his night okay
so how can I actually punish this night
see form maybe Queen here because Nazi
Fargo go broke a 81
hmm so what happens if I've had take it
what have five time warning okay I mean
just I mean if black can play all this
yeah maybe he can but how - hard to
believe all this okay so what kind of
lines are they have seven is hanging I'm
also threatening Queeny for picking up
the rook and a five is just stranded
also no idea I mean also if he gives me
just one movie I play okay so what now
Bishop f7 King Queen takes Queen e5
something like this but it's maybe not
entirely entirely winning I'm sorry but
I need to I need to move him okay he can
pick up III sure but now I've got rook
e1 coming he's all tied down with his
pieces
he's got three pieces for Rukia which
should be winning but I mean I really
hope this attacker wins now everything
else I would consider you Julie hugely
unfair really but okay maybe I didn't
didn't play the best also very lightly
okay but this looks winning now rook e8
check yeah bishop and this is midnight
shift mate yeah hard to tell in a three
minute game it all was super provocative
what he played them or the computer
actually gives us as completely winning
right the right hunch there okay yeah
computer wants to take on f7
I have all this looks really honing it
really good yeah yeah this is completely
winning this maybe yeah computer says
it's equal funny yeah okay well doesn't
matter so much what the computer
calculates yeah the three minute game
this is close to impossible to defend
all right let's request the next game
here and it really takes a while to to
get a game really not not used to this
normally you just get them one after the
other game started alright there we go
let's play you fall again another
Sicilian yet the Dragons always always
surprised how popular this opening
really is still I mean Black is losing
so much with this but well people seem
to like it okay I played some um
positional line not the Yugoslavia tech
with the long castles but amorphous
strategical line which doesn't look too
threatening for black but it has some
points I mean g5 and h5 well hard to
believe okay so I'll complete my
development here I want to play 95 of
the course and now we can can do it this
is just a nice piece and it's hard for
him to tolerate this night but if he
takes I'll capture with the pawn and
then get the e-file open okay I don't
want to exchange this vision obviously
his g7 bishop is a good good defending
piece so we're now g5 maybe just g5 Wow
okay 94 f5 something like this doesn't
look too bad
and I could could think of FC is playing
this school we could think about this I
was trying to to say and grabbing H form
I mean
96 and so on some looks really really a
bit much but okay he's attacking be too
old so yeah I'll just I just cover this
play it play it simple you know okay you
can have this phone so how to continue
here like to get rid of one night here
this Bishop on f1 is not doing so much I
could I could play Bishop f5 also or
maybe this one ruining a temple and
maybe even Queen h6 year queen h6 to h5
they're also threatening queen h7 now
and everything's hanging basically how
does he protect it now King FA deploy 96
check and twin dolls we should be six
also was wasn't bad but I don't see a
movie at all on this move
yeah no more I think it just loses lots
of material not pleased peace
yeah no move yeah I'm not sure but I had
this whole whole thing it was up
advancing on the kingside and grabbing
all those pawns and such kind of reasons
we can't believe this that you can play
this alright so the next game maybe I
get to get a quicker game so what's the
score for this session here let's check
weekly not too bad actually five games
and I just conceded one draw okay so one
a couple of points where got four wide
four wide games in a row funny I mean
not in a row but for white games out of
out of five out of five total surprising
and stole some waiting time here between
games started okay a black game okay
let's check the King's idiot hmm okay
what's he doing
oh yeah style of the the world
championship match transposing to
sandwich yeah there are all kinds of
lines here that black can play I'm
trying to play something less less
coming here this is aiming for could
play on the on the queenside combining
two inside and central play so
a bit out of fashion this kind of setup
but it's not not really bad I mean also
not great but it's it's playable
okay so trying to open up the position
here aha
interesting isn't this nice now I don't
know
yeah yeah okay it's got a four it's good
if all protected yeah and I've got a
very weird Bishop on b7 hmm yeah maybe
this is quite good for white could be
young night night night c5 I was more
more afraid of 95 okay but it's not like
that that I would have here green oh
okay I want to activate pieces here give
give up the exchange but I want to cover
this e5 and e6 squares and some I don't
know otherwise I'm so passive didn't
like it maybe I can get something going
on the King here it's certainly not the
kind of 100% correct sacrifice but maybe
I can get some play here
not sure don't see a direct reputation
and is taking some time okay so maybe c5
now c5 would activate activating the
bishop okay at least I'm threatening
something Bishop takes them f3 okay now
I can I'm going to actually enter here
right now this Bishop you know God get
I'm getting something going here let's
open it up here
queef all night if - okay waiting quite
quite some material here for for the
Queen not quite sure if this is working
okay can stupid you can just count the
sacrifice and and I'm I'm down the
material just an exchange yeah I mean
okay I could I could actually resign him
after maybe he makes some technical
mistakes yeah this actually isn't 100%
easy
what's now no move or some disconnection
here I mean this is technically not not
so easy if white forfeits on time okay
yeah I don't know maybe some connection
issue or something hmm
yeah okay I mean okay white should win
here but it's technically not easy at
all in such time at least maybe white
should take f7 and then try to run with
the king all the way to e8 difficult
okay so request a new game last one for
the session to get some 40 45 minute
video
yeah it looked it looked promising I
mean this kind of position really I
really liked computer gives white
close to winning advantage all the time
yeah you see no it wants to take on f3
and play Knight f2 cool oh yeah see
forces this was not working I mean
what's the political star okay that's a
new game here and maybe this is sort of
a match point forgetting the 2200 maybe
okay Sun which was posted to a French
defense here the Makassar variation and
he's playing very quickly oh okay I
don't know the opening just
experimenting him so
Kame is attacking you for so what does
black play him okay maybe I can first
detect the Queen okay now
hmm strike in the center so yeah
non-threatening Queen c3 this looks a
bit bit ugly okay
so if I take now it's got Bishop d2 okay
I need to clarify this here and now
thread 94 again
yeah my dark squares are obviously a
very weak
hmm Queen f6 in particular is quite
quite dangerous hmm
okay losing e4 is not so terrible okay
maybe maybe I need to to cover cover
those and now trying to play Bishop to
c6 he can grab a pawn but okay yeah he's
playing very quickly butcher has its
benefits obviously but once in a while
thinking might might help our
threatening made on g2 and the bishop is
saying so how does he save his bishop
now yeah I think he had a pretty pretty
promise pretty promising it's a pretty
promising position but yeah yeah you
need to in west time once in a while at
least a couple of seconds to to avoid
blundering pieces answer in such I think
I just win this now
hmm yeah now he lets the clock run down
doesn't seem to find a move
yeah this is for instance the played in
four seconds
I mean y-you can think of all kinds of
moves Queen B seven rope to whatever D 1
B 1 and this also played played almost
instantly
I mean after Bishop Sizzix you you
really need to recognize that this long
diagonal is quite quite dangerous and
okay this immediately wins a piece and
now he lets the clock run down brilliant
but I'll get the point in 10 seconds
white foreheads on time yeah actually
made it to 2200 a1 here and in this
session on that check quickly yeah I
really only considered one draw here but
very sketchy play I mean also winning on
time and and stuff alright so thanks for
watching I hope you liked it it was more
entertainment than then educational
maybe but thanks for watching anyway and
talk to you soon with new stuff